Tony Taylor a local counselor who worked
at the steelworks for more than 40 years
is at Port Albert for us tonight and
Frank fields the chairman of the Work
and Pensions Select Committee is also in
our Westminster studio thank you
gentlemen for joining us
Tony Taylor first of all is this a
moment to celebrate or is it really a
moment to commiserate I think it's a
moment we've gotta face reality and be
pragmatic
there wasn't much a choice on offer
today or the Dumas period it was either
take it or leave it which I very
disappointed with because no one knew
what the plan B was going to be were
they good to go back to the same process
and if they went back to the same
process would the bidders still be
interested but there's been a decision
taken now we've got to move on in the
future we've got to make sure the Tata
stands up to the plate and delivers on
their proposals there's disappointment
there you're a former still working
yourself for many years also a total
pension or at least the British still
pension it does it affect you yes it's
good of subshock effect because you
don't know what the provisions of the
current scheme is going to be we've had
a number of proposals put forward by the
chairman of the trustees well you're a
communication so we've got to sit there
and wait and see what happens in the
future for freshers pensioners and what
happens to the people that's what can
you say to plant because they just is
important as well Frank fields excuse
that metaphor but is this the canary in
the coal mine I mean so many businesses
around the UK established businesses
having real trouble with their pension
schemes are we going to see more of this
in the future probably and I think the
men are to be congratulated on their
their vote because they I say men
because it would be very largely a male
population working at the in the firms a
incredibly difficult decision for them
to have to make I hope I'd have had the
courage to make the same decision
because they are voting for life really
but with reduced pensions benefits and I
would make one plain out of the trade
unions who from that film we saw clearly
in some difficulty with some of the
workforce pensions are a property right
just like your house um and people have
in effect given over part of their
property to make a success of the firm
and the next stage of its life and I
would hope the trade unions will get
written into any agreement two things
one is that if in fact better times come
as I think they will come then this
these cuts can actually be reviewed so
we don't have a further transfer of from
working people to the owners of capital
but also that worry that and I think the
Prime Minister has to take an interest
in this that given up on those work
people who have made the decision today
that she now takes more than an interest
and active interest in ensuring that
Tata doesn't now decide to Palm off what
they own here to somebody else maybe in
Europe or well beyond that I am the we
heard the men expressing worries on that
school they're dead right to be worried
on that school and it would be
disgraceful if they were actually
treated in the way that some people fear
but on that Toni Taylor I mean is is
there concern trepidation locally at the
moment or is there a sense of closure
for for Talbot and indeed the steel
community I got a business sense of
closure there is a sense of I'm there
there's a sense of frustration that the
deal has been no going to be done that
people are saying that there's going to
be a billion pound invested in the plant
over ten years there's caveats to that
that the company must make a 200 million
pound property over before they will
levy that money in there's a little word
that says they will try to avoid
compulsory redundancies try in this
context is a huge word so you must say
the Tartu you know we need
understanding what's going on who need
better communication and it's gonna take
a while for the rift inside the works to
heal and it's going to take a time for
that understanding our trust between
employers and employees you built back
up for the future is there anything that
can actually be done now I mean you know
a lot of people very disappointed by
this a lot of people feeling this this
you know was a difficult Ovidius
decision but they had to take it but
they're looking towards government's and
wondering whether there is anything that
can be done well they could have made
another decision so I think we should
actually say to them well done because
they're the only group so far in the
community that's been asked to surrender
part of what I think is their capital
savings
nobody else has been put through the
rigor of the work people here and
therefore is nothing will be you think
it will happen more and more may well be
and therefore if we're to safeguard what
is of the these difficult firms which
have gigantic pension schemes to keep
the firms going until we actually we get
into times and in different interest
rates so that the firms can begin to
actually rebalance that will the
interest rate markets where as interest
comes so you're thinking of other firms
you know that are also facing those
problems well we know there's a huge
list in them with these mega deficits
but as interest rates start to rise as
they were assuredly in the near future
the the losses on the pension scheme
become less and less with the interest
rate rises doesn't mean to say that
other people don't lose out but it does
actually make pension funding more
manageable and therefore given the lead
that Tartu workforces given I think
there's a moral duty now on the prime
minister first of all to take the
particular interest in tarter and be
talking to the owners of charter but
also to put to push up her agenda what's
going to happen to other firms weighed
down by their pension funds okay Toni
Taylor can I just ask you very quickly
sorry
Tony said the what's your message very
quickly to tartar still thinking
potentially still about a sale what
would you say to them I think they've to
move quickly now to build up trust and
you know reveal some of your long-term
plans not short-term because we don't be
stunned in your in 18 months or two
years time discussing the potential
closure or a potential sale it's been a
hard 12 months for them people inside
that plan they've had to make this hard
decision at the end of it and there was
no plan B it was a take-it-or-leave-it
and tates got to work hard now to
rebuild that trust